[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Hi there.
Heather again.
MORGAN MCLEAN: And hi.
I'm Morgan.
I'm product manager
on Stackdriver.
HEATHER CROSS: So
keeping tabs on your apps
and dealing with errors
can involve multiple tools
from multiple vendors, and
this is far from ideal.
And you really want all the
tools you need in one place,
right?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Absolutely,
which is why on this episode,
we'll be talking
about Stackdriver,
a one-stop shop for all
the DevOps services on GCP.
We'll also run through a quick
demo of the self-paced lab,
where we'll show you
how to monitor a GCE VM
instance with Stackdriver.
[SWIPING SOUND]
HEATHER CROSS:
Stackdriver provides
powerful monitoring, logging,
and diagnostics for apps
across cloud platforms.
It equips you with insights
into your health, performance,
and availability of
cloud-powered apps,
enabling you to find
and fix issues faster.
MORGAN MCLEAN: That's right.
Setting up system-level
and app-level monitoring
is one of the most
common DevOps tasks,
which makes monitoring
one of the key features
of Stackdriver.
HEATHER CROSS: So let's take
a look at monitoring first.
Stackdriver Monitoring
collects metrics, events,
and metadata from GCP, AWS, and
a variety of common application
components.
You can then create alerts
and dashboards on this data.
Next, let's take a look
at logging and errors.
Stackdriver Logging allows you
to filter, search, and view
logs from your code and your
cloud's provider services.
You can also export these logs
into BigQuery, Cloud Storage,
and Pub/Sub for
further analysis.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Stackdriver
Error Reporting
monitors your
application's errors,
aggregates them,
and then alerts you
to any new issues that arise.
You can use the error
reporting console
to see data about the instances
of these errors, the versions
of your app in
which they occurred,
and when they were
first or last seen.
[SWIPING SOUND]
APM is a new brand
that we're using
for our tools, AMPI developers,
and root cause analysis.
These three tools can be used on
applications running anywhere,
including GCP, AWS,
Azure, or on-premises.
The first is Stackdriver
Trace, which is our distributed
tracing tool.
It allows you to view
how requests propagate
across all of your
services, so that you
can improve their latency.
It also analyzes these
traces to inform you
about latency trends over time,
or across different versions
of your code.
HEATHER CROSS: Stackdriver
Debugger is quite magical.
It effectively enables
production breakpoints
so that you don't stop or slow
down customer interactions
with your service.
Debugger can also
add log statements
to your production code
without requiring redeployment.
This is a very
impressive tool that we
use every day at
Google, and we're
excited to offer you
the same functionality.
MORGAN MCLEAN:
Stackdriver Profiler
was just launched into beta.
It allows you to see how your
code executes in production,
giving you insight into CPU
or memory-hungry functions,
so that you can improve
performance and reduce
your costs.
[SWIPING SOUND]
HEATHER CROSS: Time
again for Quick Labs.
This hands-on lab will show you
how to monitor Compute Engine
VM instance with Stackdriver.
You'll also install monitoring
and logging agents for your VM.
MORGAN MCLEAN: You
can check out the link
to start the Quick Lab here.
Keep in mind that the lab
will take about 40 minutes
to complete.
At this point of the lab,
you've created a compute engine
instance, an Apache HTTP
server for the instance.
You've created a Stackdriver
account for your project,
and you've created an uptime
check and an alerting policy.
So let's create a
chart for CPU load.
Create a chart for received
packets on the network.
Name your dashboard
with the two new charts.
Test the check and alert
by stopping your instance.
Note the incident notice
on the Monitoring Overview
page in Stackdriver.
View the logs for
your VM by clicking
on Stackdriver Logging.
HEATHER CROSS: Well,
there we have it.
We hope you enjoyed this
episode on Stackdriver.
MORGAN MCLEAN:
Don't forget to keep
visiting our on-air
webinar series, Quick
Labs, and our blogs.
All of the links are below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: You can also
learn more about Stackdriver
through our Google Cloud
on-demand courses on Coursera.
Thanks for watching,
and we'll see you soon.
Ever wondered how you could
automate triggers in your app?
Well, check out
last week's episode,
where we demo a cloud function.
[MUSIC PLAYING]